welcome back to las vegas now on this
new year's day it's time to get cooking
with nanny bubby she is sharing a fast
recipe for homemade chicken cacciatore
check it out
oh hello happy holidays to all of you
well i'll tell you there's nothing i
like more than a warm
flannel shirt during the holidays when
the nights are so cold
and the days are crisp but still very
very cold
and what i love so much is that
even though we're not doing the
traditional holidays where we're running
to
office parties or everybody else's
holiday parties
we're still very very busy and why
because so many of us
are making we're crafting we're cooking
we're doing things at home that we've
never really done before and that's
really costing us a lot of time it's
time we love but nonetheless but today
what i have for you
is a great recipe that if you get behind
in your holiday
wrapping and making that when it comes
to dinner time i'm going to give you a
fun and easy way to make a great dinner
for whomever you're feeding
so what i'm making for you is a really
really
quick chicken cacciatore and it starts
with already cooked chicken i'll show
you that in a minute but first
i'm starting with the onions you can see
just they're very big pieces
and we're going to take those and put
them right into the pot
and start sweating them and so while
we're sweating the onions
let's cut the peppers
[Music]
so you may be wondering what's so quick
about this recipe
and the answer is it's the chicken the
chicken
is an already cooked chicken i've
already
cut this one up but i'm going to show
you how easy this is
when they're already cooked and
refrigerated
you're just going to pull off
there's a lid there's another one
you're going to tear off the back
[Music]
well this is cooking up so beautifully
you can smell it it's great we're just
adding the garlic so it doesn't burn we
put it in right before
we put in all the other ingredients and
then we're going to throw in some
already sliced up mushrooms
they will skinny down
they will sweat down on their own in the
sauce
and we're gonna add salt and pepper
about two teaspoons of salt
especially if you bought a chicken that
was not seasoned
you want to add some good flavor and
a teaspoon of pepper to give it some
heat
and we're going to stir this around and
are you ready
here's where things get really easy and
fun we're going to take
two 28 ounce cans of
fire roasted chopped tomatoes into the
pot
into the pot and to give it great
flavor we're going to add my favorite
that i use with everything the rayoz
arabiata sauce which has got a lot of
spice and heat to it
so good right into the pot we're going
to stir this around
and into the pot goes the chicken
we're gonna let it cook for about an
hour
just to get all the flavors to melt
together ready here we go
[Music]
and so now this is my favorite part
about having a garden out back
is i came out here and clipped some
rosemary oregano and basil to throw
into the chicken cacciatore
and that's it everybody so easy
happy making whatever it is you're
making while you're home
this pairs nicely with a great glass of
red
italian wine served with a baguette
sliced up so you can dip into the sauce
eat your chicken
and no stress have a wonderful holiday
season everyone and remember
spread love like butter that is a
beautiful dish check out nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden on social media and
online at nannybubby.com we also want to
thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment we'll be right